well Democrats in the house are making
their loudest overtures yet toward
impeachment as they begin their summer
recess they've asked a court for
documents from Muller's investigation
that Judiciary Chairman Jerry Nadler
says are needed for an impeachment
inquiry Nancy Cordes has details from
Capitol Hill antsy we're crossing a
threshold absolutely in a parting shot
before a six-week break Democrats said
they are stepping up their probe of the
president I would say we are in an
impeachment investigation it could lead
to articles of impeachment or it could
lead to something else in a federal suit
the House Judiciary Committee is seeking
underlying grand jury testimony from the
Muller investigation especially material
related to president Trump's knowledge
of any potential criminal acts by him or
his aides
the suit says the house is considering
whether to exercise a constitutional
power of the utmost gravity approval of
articles of impeachment all they want to
do is impede they want to investigate
they want to go fishing the move comes
as some Democrats grow frustrated with
the speaker's more cautious approach to
impeachment the decision will be made in
a timely fashion
speaker Pelosi cleared the air with one
critic New York congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez
tensions between the two over strategy
and policy had grown personal in recent
weeks the two sides trading barbs in the
press and online do you think you were
able to bury the hatchet with
congresswoman Ocasio Cortez in your
meeting I don't think there was any
hatchet well she called you downright
disrespectful no that's that's that's
we're in a political arena in our caucus
we have our differences respect that the
closed-door meeting lasted about half an
hour with both lawmakers downplaying
their disagreements after they left for
CBS this morning Saturday I'm Nancy
Cordes on Capitol Hill